Musik Freund, ich grüsse dich. Ha, Baktus. Oh nein. Ah ja, das war es leider schon. Oh nein. Sehr, sehr schön. Ach, das Florian-Regime kappt alle Kreativität, erstickt es im Keim, abgekappt. Nur die Begrenzung macht Kreativität überhaupt möglich. Und deswegen vielen, vielen Dank an Christopher, wie dieser Operette Opus A-Moll, die er uns geschickt hat in dem großen Dentalzyklus. Und zwar Opus I, Bactus. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was Opus II werden wird. Ich finde es nach wie vor fantastisch. Karies und Bactus klingt ja tatsächlich einfach wie eine Oper. Ja. Elektra, Richard Strauss, ich verstehe, in dieser Reihe verstehe ich Tristan und Isolde, Karius und Baktus. Karius und Baktus, die gemeinsam, ich finde auch gut, dass so Bösewicht-Duos existieren, auch in der echten physischen Welt, wo man einfach sagt, okay, es gibt Pest und Cholera, es gibt Karius und Baktus. Das sind einfach Duo Bösewichte, die treten zusammen auf. Ich finde das grossartig. Sehr, sehr schön. Immer noch eine fantastische Idee, darüber nochmal eine Oper zu machen. Vielen, vielen Dank für den ersten Hinweis. Hüsterich und Schnieferinchen. Und ihr hört es vielleicht, Hüsterich ist immer noch bei mir eingezogen. Er saugt mir die Lebenskräfte aus. Ich kriege ihn nicht aus der Tür rausgetreten. Ich bin zu höflich, ich bin nicht unhöflich genug, ich gebe Hinweise so, ja, ich muss jetzt auch los, langsam, aber Hüsterich leider, er geht nicht. Also ihr müsst leider noch eine weitere Folge mit dem Florentin K. aushalten, mittlerweile ein komplett neues Subgenre unter Podcast UFO, eine weitere Krankfolge. Es gibt einige Leute daraus und die freuen sich jetzt. Die meisten werden eher aufseufzen. Deswegen vielen, vielen Dank für ... Oh. Domini Patris Sanctus Domini, ich bin dem Tode geweiht, meine letzten Atemzüge stehen mir vor. Florentin Wild ist ganz doll krank, er ist bettlägerig und sollte eigentlich in eine heisse Wanne. Wir nehmen unsere Hände in die Höhe und fassen unsere Nachbarn an und schreien im Chor. Wir beten für dich, Florentin. Wir fassen uns an den Händen, werfen sie in die Höhe und drehen uns im Kreis.
Kreise wackelt mit den Ärschen, als gäbe es keinen Morgen und geht einmal tief runter.
Das ist der Boogie, das ist der Boogie, wir gehen runter und fassen uns in den Schritt.
Zeigt, was eure Mutter euch gegeben hat. Und werdet furchtbar. Ja, die Kirche muss natürlich auch jetzt nach dem, der Papst ist tot leider, ich glaube, der soll das jetzt hier anzeigen. Die Glocke läutet ein letztes Mal, wir wissen es nicht, wir sind in unserem UFO abgeschirmt von allem, was da draußen passiert, wir kriegen das nur durch solche Audiosignale hier mit. Diese Glocken ist lustig, dass wir jetzt, wir sind ja, wie ihr bei Patreon sicherlich schon festgestellt hat, in einem anderen Studio zu Gast. Liebe Grüße an die Dudes, wo wir vorübergehend aufnehmen. Das habe ich doch schon gesagt, den Schal gibt es im Podcast UFO Merch Store, den könnt ihr euch da einfach besorgen und bestellen. Wir sind bei den Dudes im Studio zu besuchen. Wir lieben die Dudes. Wir wollen uns bei denen bedanken, aber wir sind halt nicht nur in einem komplett anderen Ort mit ganz anderen Menschen, ganz woanders. Trotzdem haben wir noch die Glocken. Die Glocken begleiten uns und Religion ist ja in diesem Podcast auch immer irgendwie schon da gewesen. Wir haben die Wunder, die mir jetzt noch zur selig Heilig-Sprechung fehlen. Eins fehlt. Eins fehlt noch. Vielleicht hilft es dich zu heilen. Das wäre gut. Du hast bisher nicht versucht, mich zu heilen. Du hast mir einmal wirklich intensiv in die Rippen getreten, aus voller Kraft. Ich weiß nicht, dass ein Heilversuch war. Mit den Bacillen. Bacillus Maximus raus! Und dann hast du mir sanft auf die Stirn geküsst, das fand ich dann schon besser. Das fand ich schon mal in Ordnung, das war ein Heilversuch. Aber mal gucken, ob es früchtet. Du hast dabei gestöhnt, ja. Ja genau, also vielen Dank an die Dutz, dass wir hier sein dürfen. Bruchlandung kann man sagen, wir sind gerade gebruchlandet auf einem anderen Planeten, auf dem Dutzplaneten, aber hier ist es ja schön, die Atmosphäre ist zum Glück atembar, wie
die meisten Planeten in den meisten
Universen zum Glück und deswegen kein
Problem. Dankeschön. Aber bitte auch
jetzt nicht uns verpetzen,
wenn die in den nächsten Folgen
bei sich im Podcast daheim
krank werden.
Nicht, dass ihr den dann so steckt,
aha, wisst ihr noch, als Flo-Routine bei
denen im Studio war und alles voll gehustet hat, weil es voll gehustet und sich einmal in jede Ecke gehustet hat und rumgepustet hat, als gäbe es keinen Morgen. Ich habe tatsächlich ein paar Mal in die Kaffeemaschine gehustet, intensiv. Kann sein, dass wenn man sich jetzt hier einen Kaffee rauslässt, wollte man sich angucken, was passiert mit dem Boden? Du hast auf dem Boden geguckt, ob da der Hersteller draufsteht. Du siehst immer nur, hier liegt eine Bohne, das kann doch nicht sein. Ich sehe nur, die Bohnen in die Kaffeemaschine wandeln, apathisch, wo mir denkt, wisst ihr nicht, was da drin mit euch passiert, liebe Bohnen? Wisst ihr nicht, dass ihr einfach zermahlen werdet, gnadenlos, aber die... Aber wie lange muss es diese Glocken an sein, damit man denkt, statt wir belagern? Das ist das Ding. Ich glaube, die Idee ist ja wirklich, dass überall Glocken stehen, dass die ganze Stadt es merkt, falls die Saracenen vor der Tür stehen, Belagerung stattfindet. Ich glaube, wir sind jetzt außerhalb der Stadtmauer, da haben wir eh relativ schlechte Karten. Nee, hier sind wir mitten in der Stadtmauer. Ah ja, okay, das ist ja gut. Na ja, weiß ich nicht, die ist ja auch gewachsen, Kölner Stadtmauer. Weiß ich nicht. Ich habe eine Burg neu besichtigt, hat mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht in Kochem. Da bin ich kurz hingefahren, hin und zurück, zack, zack, einfach kurz hin, habe mir die Burg angeguckt. Man sagt ja gut, besser, Kochem. Der Slogan von Kochem. Das ist der Slogan von Kochem. Die sind nach wie vor offen für andere Vorschläge, also sehr, sehr offen sogar. Da steht auch ein Sternchen dran und dann ruft gerne an, weil sie eine bessere, dass sie die Tür haben rausnehmen lassen. Also man kann da einfach reingehen und andere Vorschläge mitteilen. Da ist die Burg von Kochen, die Reichsburg heißt sie, steht da rum. Und dann waren wir da, Kumpel und ich sind hingefahren und uns anguckt. Dann kamen wir da an und Führung gab es. Wir dachten, ah, fuck, ist es ein bisschen zu spät, gibt es noch eine Führung? Ja, in 15 Minuten kam man in Durchsage, kommt die nächste Führung, wir waren die einzigen beiden. Die einzigen beiden in der Führung. Und du kennst mich und ich lieb das und ich gehe dann so auf in diesen Führungen, wo man unter sich ist, ich stelle alle Fragen, die mir einfallen, ich labere einfach drauf los, ich liebe das, ich bin ein riesen Fan von. Und war das eine Führung auch mit einem Menschen in Gewandung, also wirklich in mittelalterlichem Kostüm, also dieses, was das von Holländer ohne Kostüm. Ah, okay. Der hat uns da durchgeführt, hat uns alles gezeigt, es gab Geheimgänge, es gab Säle mit den coolsten Möbeln, die ich so gar nicht kannte, fand ich fantastisch, da hab ich nämlich gesagt, das muss zurück. Und zwar, ich elaboriere. Die hatten ein, erstmal finde ich ja sowieso geil, im Mittelalter, wenn du Burgherr warst, dann ist da sehr viel Platz, sehr viele Zimmer, sehr viel Platz. Und jedes Zimmer hat einen Zweck, es sind oft monothematische Zimmer. Du bist das Gegenteil von dem, was wir heute haben. Heute haben wir Open Floor, Open Space Living, da haben wir Wohnzimmer, Küche, Essbereich, oft alles in einem und oft wollen wir das auch, weil wir große Räume haben wollen. Gut, Platzprobleme hatten die jetzt nicht, deswegen grosse Räume haben die sowieso, aber dann gibt es das Jagdzimmer, dann gibt es das Billardzimmer, dann gibt es das Herrentrinkzimmer, dann gibt es das was auch immer, Schlafzimmer und so, klar, aber eben so Hobbyräume, ja, nein, da jetzt nicht, da jetzt nicht, aber bei, ich weiß noch, als ich bei Mozart in der Wohnung war. Posthum, muss man dazu sagen, ja, Posthum. Was wolltest du jetzt dazu sagen? Ich wollte es nicht einfach klarstellen, dazu sagen, ja. Ich mag es gerne, wenn du im Raum stehst, als ich bei Mozart war. Ja, Posthum. Dann wolltest du jetzt dazu sagen. Ich wollte es nicht einfach klarstellen, dazu sagen. Ich mag es gerne, wenn du im Raum stehst, als ich beim Mozart war. Ja, Posthum. Beim Mozart. Beim Wolfgang. Wolfi. Ja, da gab es sowas. Aber es gibt so Spielzimmer, oder? Das Jagdzimmer. So, und dann gibt es halt auch das Zimmer, wo man sich getroffen hat. Nicht zum Essen, nicht zum Speisen, also Speisestimmer, nein, es war ein, so ein Trinkzimmer, was auch immer, so ein Raum, wo man dann nach dem Essen rein ist, am Kamin sich hingesetzt hat und halt getrunken hat.
Das hat man schon daran erkannt, dass das Schlüsselloch eingeführt war. Das heisst, wenn man besoffen war und man hat seinen Schlüssel da hingepackt, haben einem so geschlosserte Linien, egal wo du hingehst, führen einen, wenn man einfach den Arm runter bewegt, führen einen Linien ins Loch, dass man einfach das Loch findet, auch wenn man schon viel zu besoffen ist. Warum hat sich das nicht durchgesetzt? Das ist doch mal eine gute Idee, die wir einfach auf dem Fussboden der Geschichte liegen gelassen haben. Haben wir liegen, haben wir vergessen, haben wir ausgeräumt, obwohl wir es noch gebraucht hätten. Aber wie besoffen muss man sein, dass man sagt, Herbert, pass mal auf, das Schloss, du hast ja das Schloss gebaut, ne, im Trinkzimmer. Das ist zu klein. Das ist zu klein und das bewegt sich hin und her und dann manchmal sind zwei Löcher da und dann drei. und dann dreht sich so im Kreis irgendwie und kann man da irgendwas machen?
Ich habe dir erklärt, also mein Gut über dein Alkoholproblem, ne, wolltest du schon mal nicht mehr. Trink halt nun mal gern. Ich habe die Saracen besiegt bei Jericho, da kann ich mir aber auch mal schön einen gönnen, da kann ich mir auch mal einen schönen kleinen Küstennebel gönnen, warum denn nicht? So, und dann machst du einfach den Arm rausstrecken mit dem Schlüssel.
Wie gesagt, habe ich dir erklärt, einfach runtergehen. Ich habe dir schon extra diese Linien gebaut, damit du einfach quasi runterrauben, rein. Okay, ich probiere es, Mensch. Nicht irgendwie jetzt. Könnt ihr ihn hinrichten, bitte? Wieso das denn jetzt? Hi, wieso das denn jetzt? Nö, nö, nö, nö, komm, komm, komm, komm, komm, komm, komm.
Aber ist natürlich, finde ich, auch praktikabel für die Zeit, weil das war natürlich eine monarchisch, stark autoritär aufgebaute Zeit, wo du in so einem Feiergelage jemanden hast, wo du sagst, so, jetzt geht's ins Trinkzimmer. Und dann gehen alle ins Trinkzimmer. Ich glaube, heute, wo du bei so einer WG-Party jetzt, gut, im Hederinge-Umfeld hat man Anführer gewählt, die Stärksten, die Stammeshäuptlinge, aber sonst ist man ja oft bei einer Party in einem Raum und man, wer würde jetzt wirklich zu sagen, so und jetzt gehen wir in den Billardraum und dann geht hier Person alleine oder alle anderen wollen zurückbleiben. Ich glaube, solche jetzt gehen wir in den Fluggiballraum, würde man heute sagen.
Ja, aber dann musst du dir sicher sein,
dass dein Standing in der Gruppe gut genug ist und das ist eine extreme soziale Herausforderung,
die, glaube ich, die wenigsten heute schaffen könnten,
weil ich finde, wir sind sozial verwahrlost, anderes Thema
in meinem Buch, da können wir auch immer drüber sprechen,
aber ich glaube, in einer Monarchie,
wo du dich ja auch zurücklehnen kannst und sagst,
ey, er macht den Abend. So, wenn er sagt,
jetzt der Abend vorbei, ist der Abend vorbei. Kassandra Cassandra, ist das Mario Kart Zimmer bereitgestellt? Jawohl, Eure Majestät, es ist bereitgestellt. Okay, ist Luigi voreingestellt mit dem grünen Kart? Luigi ist bereits voreingestellt auf 150 Kubikzentimeter Hubraum, mein Lord. Sehr gut, Regenburgenboulevard als Strecke voreingestellt, ist alles bereit? Ist bereits als Strecke eingestellt, ja, ihr habt bereits zwei Minuten Vorsprung auf der Strecke, Maylord. Kassandra, sehr gut, sind die Items voreingestellt für mich besser als für die anderen? Richtig, die Items wurden so eingestellt, dass sie die besten Items bekommen, unter anderem die Rakete, den Stern und den Superstern. So, meine Herren, wir sind bereit. Jawohl, und dann kommt ein gesamtes Gefolge mit und dann kannst du das so machen. Ich finde ja manchmal so ein bisschen Autorität nicht schlecht bei so einer Party. Wenn du jemanden hast, der dann sagt, so, jetzt machen wir das, jetzt ist Pause, generell für mich ein riesen Green Flag bei einer Partyeinladung, gibt der jetzt immer, Hochzeit, irgendwie Junggesellen, Gedöns, wir kommen ja langsam wohl mal sagen. Und da finde ich es geil, wenn auf der Einladung schon das Ende steht. Das ist so fantastisch. Ich fühle mich so wohl, auf eine Party zu gehen, wo ich weiß, ein Uhr wurde davor als Ende festgelegt. Finde ich fantastisch. Grossartig. Du weißt, ah, ein Uhr, jetzt bin ich raus. Riesen Green Flag für mich. Von Geschenken möchte ich absehen. Ich bitte für das nur meine Spende
an, auch Riesen Greg Flag.
Greg Flag?
Riesen Green Flag.
Weil ich möchte
nicht so gerne mir
und klar, bei Leuten,
wenn man sich so richtig eng ist, wenn man so richtig eng
befreundet ist, dann kann man auch
trotzdem was schenken, wenn man das gerne möchte.
Weil wir haben schon oft darüber gesprochen. Wir hatten doch gesprochen, Geschenke sind für den Schenkenden. Nicht umgekehrt. Deswegen meine ich, wenn ihr euch dann sehr was Gutes zumutztet, dann schenkt eurem Freund was. Aber wenn es da drauf steht, und man oft ist das wie ein Pferder bekannter, ich finde das mega, muss man sich keine Gedanken machen. Weil oft machen wir uns nichts vor. Oft ist es doch einfach so, zwei Stunden vor Party sagt man, haben wir eigentlich ein Geschenk? Ah, bei wem kann ich mitschenken? Kann ich nicht noch mitschenken? Ah ne, der Gutschein wurde schon gekauft, ah ne, wir haben jetzt irgendwie blablabla. Ja, komm, ich cash rein, ja, aber nee, jetzt haben alle schon bezahlt. Ja, und, aber ich hol mir mein Taschenrechner raus und sag. Der Toaster hat 20 Euro gekostet, wir haben jetzt schon 14 Leute, die hinter diesen 20-Euro-Toaster stehen. Ab einem gewissen Punkt wird es albern. Wir können nicht einfach sagen, die gesamte Familienseite der Braut schenkt einen Toaster von Aldi, von Medion für 1999. Nimm noch die Zehner und dann macht die so zusammen und klickt die so zusammen und dann kannst du einen Toaster machen oder in den Toaster rein oder so. Aber was ist jetzt also, mal als Moral, Immanuel Kant, Sie sitzen vor uns, angenommen, da ist jetzt zum Spendenaufruf gebeten für etwas, das man nicht unterstützt. Beispiel Luchse. Ja, ich kenne das auch bei einem Geburtstag von einer Bekannten, die meinte, keine Geschenke spendet an Luchse. Und ich dachte mir, die scheiß Luchse fressen mir die Rüben aus dem Garten raus, die kommen bei mir rein, die greifen meinen Hund an, bei die scheiß Luchse, die kacken mir auf die Einfahrt von meiner Villa, das ist nervig, ich hab keinen Bock auf die Luchse, die soll ich schützen, nee, ganz im Gegenteil, ich spende 10 Euro für die Luchse und 100 Euro für die Anti-Luchs, ich schiesse die Dreckstbiester ab Stiftung. Du hast selber gesagt, Kant, Moral, handeln nur nach derlei Maxime, von denen du wollen kannst, dass sie zum allgemeinen Gesetz werden. Und da macht er genau den Unterschied. Viele sagen jetzt, hätten den einfachen Weg gewählt. War Maxime, ging es nicht um Maxime? Und übersetzen es falsch mit, was du nicht willst, das meint du, das will gar keinem anderen zu. Das ist falsch. Hier geht es mehr um das grosse Ganze und die Gesellschaft als etwas komplexes Grosses zu verstehen. Du kannst nicht wollen, dass man Luchse, das ist zu kurz gedacht. Doch, die Drecksbüste, die stecken mir mal im Müll drin. Die stecken mir, bei dir, bei dir. Immanuel, pass mal auf, ich hab gestern Curry King mehr gemacht. Schön nachts noch raus und dann die Frau, bring den Müll raus, das stinkt die Küche voll. Also gehe ich raus mit Curry King, bringe ich extra in die Mülltonne rum. Ja, aber kannst du wollen, pass mal auf, nächster Morgen kamen die scheiß Luchse wieder in der Nacht, reissen die Curry King Packung raus, schmeissen die Mülltonne um, alles verstreut der ganze Müll über die ganze Einfahrt. So, und ich soll dir noch Geld geben dafür? Für was? Wofür? Okay, also du willst jetzt wirklich, dass ich meinen kategorischen Imperativ ändere in, handeln nur nach dererlei Maxime, von denen du wollen kannst, dass sie zum allgemeinen Gewächs ausser Luchse. Die sind scheiße. Tötet die alle, ich hasse die, Drecksluchse. Das soll mit rein, ja, ja. Das soll mit rein. Aber es ist nicht mehr so catchy. Das ist egal, das soll mit rein. Weißt du, wie catchy es war, zu sagen, handeln nur nach dererlei Maxime, von denen du wollen kannst, dass sie zum allgemeinen Gesetz werden. Du hast es jedes Mal, das Wort Maxime fehlt immer noch. Das ist das zentrale Wort. Handeln nur nach dererlei Maxime. Naja, aber finde ich auch schwierig. Ich mag das sehr, einfach bei Hochzeiten. Schreibt eine Endzeit, lächerlich frühe Zeit. Ja. Wir machen 23 Uhr vorbei und wir bitten, von Geschenken abzusehen. Punkt. Auch nicht in Spendenzweck, gar nichts, einfach nur maximal wenig Aufwand, minimals auf. Du, Ijooma, ich habe ein Gegenwartscheck-Angebot für dich. Nina, ich freue mich, steht drei zu acht, wir geben uns alle Punkte gerne, bitte. Ijo, mal pass auf, und zwar wir natürlich als die sogenannte Gegenwart der Zeitpodcast haben uns natürlich auf die Fahnen geschrieben, das Gegenwärtige abzubilden. Und ich finde, das Gegenwärtige findet sich vor allem immer in der Sprache wieder, wie wir sprechen, aber vor allem auch wie die Werbung spricht. Und heute habe ich etwas ganz Interessantes gesehen, denn wir erinnern uns natürlich, welches Satzzeichen hat vor allem die letzten Jahrzehnte in den neunzigern die Werbung beherrscht, natürlich das Ausrüffezeichen, gut, billig, Ausrüffezeichen, Job, Ausrüffezeichen, heute war ich das erste Mal in einem Supermarkt bei der Getränkeabteilung und über den Getränken stand in so Lettern, die da angebracht wurden, stand erfrischend Punkt.
Kein Ausruhezeichen, sondern ein Punkt.
Ende eines Satzes. Und jetzt möchte ich dich fragen, Ijoma Griechen, Punkt dafür.
Erstmal, du hast noch nicht gesagt, du hast generell noch nie gesagt, warum das jetzt gerade was nicht.
Ja, das kommt ja jetzt, weil ich sage, die Euphorie der 90er Jahre ist vorbei.
Ja, dass sich nicht satt essen können an der Gegenwart, sich nicht satt essen können an der Realität.
Nachdem wir das, was wir so, weil ich sage, die Euphorie der 90er Jahre ist vorbei. Ja, dass sich nicht satt essen können an der Gegenwart, sich nicht satt essen können an der Realität.
Nein, wir alle denken bei Erfrischung an den Kaloriengehalt, an Koffein, das nicht gesund ist, an all das denken wir heute natürlich.
Und deswegen ist auch Erfrischung etwas Statisches.
Es ist nicht mehr etwas, worum man sich freuen kann, weil all das mitkommt. Und auch sind wir eine Gesellschaft des Stillstandes.
Wir mögen den Punkt, im Englischen sagt man ja full stop,
also des Stillstandes, man sagt, es ist erfrischend.
Nicht, yeah, erfrischend, ich gehe raus,
sondern man mag die kleines bisschen Sicherheit,
die dieser Punkt gibt in unseren Unsicherheiten,
unsicherheiten, ist ein viel versprechenderes Angebot
als die Euphorie des Ausrufezeichens.
Deswegen für mich der Punkt, das Satzzeichen der Gegen den punkt muss ich leider verwehren weil ich das also dieses punkten generell satzzeichen nina ich habe dir die nieder dass du deine fucking fresse halten sollst wenn ich rede ich finde es hat doch ein über unsere Streitkultur auf, dass du wirklich niveauloser Bastard mir hier gegenüber sitzt und mir wirklich seit Folgen keinen Punkt gibt. Alter, du Wichser, nee, jetzt pass mal auf, es steht vier zu 186. Du hast mal vier Punkte, 186. Ich weiß gar nicht, was du überhaupt machst, was du überhaupt hier machst, weil du noch nie etwas Vernünftiges gesagt hast? Dein Buch ist richtig dumm. Nee, ich finde, du hast den Punkt nicht verdient, weil das etwas ist, was ich schon super lange beobachte, dass man diesen Punkt hinten setzt. Satzzeichen sind, und ich glaube, die Sparkasse wird damit auch schon seit 2006 oder sowas, auch in Zeiten, ich glaube, es ist immer als Konstante, es steht schon drin, ich gucke nach links, die Dudes haben das auch als Punkt. Ja. Es ist schon recht verbreitet und ich glaube, dass man doch eigentlich in Supermärkten gerade eher, was viel mehr Sinn ergeben würde, glaube ich, ist für gute Laune anzutreffen. Ja, aber jetzt eben aktuell nicht. Jetzt eben aktuell nicht. Es verbreitet sich jetzt auch auf den Supermarkt. Der Punkt, der kommt in die Supermärkte.
Komm, gib mir einen Punkt, gib mir einen Punkt.
Okay, du gibst den Punkt.
Dankeschön, dankeschön.
Nee, ist doch gut.
Danke.
Ich habe beobachtet, dass viele gerade Down-Step-Jacken tragen.
Nee, konnte ich irgendwie nicht beobachten. Du dummer Bastard-Spacken. Werbung. Jetzt schon? Ich bin hingefallen. Wieder. Hingestürzt. Ich bin, ja. Wie hieß es nochmal? Hinschlagen. Hingeschlagen, ja genau.
Wir erinnern uns, es gab die Folge Hinschlagen, meine ich. Richtig, mit dem Quickboard, wie hieß es nochmal, das Busseboard. Ach so, ich bin schon mehrere Mal hingeschlagen. Busseboard und dann von dem Taekwondo-Landesmeister wurdest du auch schon hingeschlagen. Du bist hingeschlagen, weil du dich selber schmatt gesetzt hast. Ich bin auch hingeschlagen mit der schwarzen Kabelschlinge. Ja, und ich bin auf der Messe meiner Uni damals hingeschlagen, weil ich mich auf so einen Kubus, auf so einen Schaumstoffkubus gelehnt habe, wo ich anderen Eltern diese Uni schmackhaft machen sollte, bin ich währenddessen hingefallen. Ähm, gut. Jetzt bin ich hingeschlagen wieder, und zwar bin ich im eisigen Berlin hingeschlagen. Es war so eisig, also wirklich so minus 10 Grad und irgendwie hat die Stadt gesagt, nee, wir streuen einfach jetzt mal nicht, mal aus Spaß, wir gucken mal, was passiert. Wir machen Eislevel aus der Stadt. So, wir machen wirklich, genau, es ist dieses klassische Mario-Kartstrecke, die in der Eiswelt spielt, Ice Age, einfach so Filme, die plötzlich in der Eiskälte spielen, whatever.
Es war einfach so fun, fun, fun.
Und es war wirklich, die Bürgersteige waren einfach
eine fucking Eisfläche,
wirklich so glatt gestriegelt
und es war arschrutschig.
Und dann bin ich da einfach hingeschlagen.
Ganz doll hingeschlagen.
Beschreib's uns, also nach vorn,
nach hinten, zur Seite, wo waren die Arme?
Schräg! Warum haben die Arme das nicht verhindern können? Also meinehindern können? Was haben die Arme als Entschuldigung vorzubringen?
Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, es war auch am schlechtmöglichsten Zeitpunkt, also ich bin gegangen, weil die Bahnen nicht mehr fuhren, deswegen bin ich gegangen.
Oh, schon so spät.
So, und dann bin ich so gegangen über so, über die, der ganze Heimweg war irgendwie angezeigt bei Google von so 20 Minuten, ich glaube ich bin 40 Minuten gegangen, da man sehr langsam nur gehen konnte, ich lerne konnte, bin schon sehr vorsichtig gegangen. Arme waren generell in einer Ruderbewegung. Konstant durchgehen. Konstant in einer Segelflieger-Ruderbewegung. Jetzt muss man sagen, ich hätte so einen Downstep-Mantel an. Die sieht man ja seit Jahren wirklich. Seit Jahren.
Deswegen war der Sturz nicht so schlimm.
Dann bin ich nämlich genau an so einer Haltestation.
Fuhren wohl die Bahn dann irgendwie doch wieder oder auch nicht mehr.
Weiß nicht, weil die ganze Bahn war voller Leute.
Und genau gegenüber schlag ich hin.
Und die Reaktion der Leute hat mir gesagt, da sind gerade mehrere Leute hingefallen, weil niemand hat reagiert, niemand hat gelacht, niemand hat geschaut. Das ist fast noch schlimmer. Aber ich hab gedacht, nee, was das Schlimmste hätte ich gefunden. Es war wie so NPCs, die einfach nicht reagiert haben. Genau, die haben weiter ihre Bewegungen gemacht. Genau, ja. Aber ich hab nichts ausgelöst bei denen und es hat nichts gemacht gemacht und das fand ich fast noch besser und beruhigender, als wenn die alle zu mir gegangen wären und gesagt, ah, der Mann ist hingeschlagen, weil wenn Leute einkommen und dem Mann helfen wollen, denke ich mir, okay, ich sah so aus, ob ich mir selber nicht mehr helfen kann, es sah sehr schlimm aus und man ist ja auch irgendwie noch das innere Kind und es geht oft um die Reaktion der anderen um und herum. Wenn ein Kind weint und alle beteiligten drumherum lachen oder ignorieren das Kind, dann ist es nicht so schlimm. Das ist die wichtigste Regel. Also immer schön weggucken, wenn ein Kind was passiert. Und da war es ein bisschen so ähnlich. Alle haben das ignoriert, haben mich da liegen lassen und so. Und deswegen fand ich es selber nicht so schlimm. Der erste Schock war ... Du hast geweint. Das langgezogene Weinen. Aber erklär uns, wie es passiert ist. Also nach vorne, nach hinten, wie lief es genau ab? Wo war der Körperschwerpunkt? Ein Fuss verlor das Gewicht, weil es wegrutschte. Nach vorne? Nach vorne. Und der andere Fuss, der dann natürlich, man hat ja zwei, man wurde ja von Gott mit zwei Füssen gesegnet. Bestraft, ja. Bestraft. Ich wollte drei, mindestens drei. Die Schlange ist gut weggekommen noch. Ohne irgendeinen. Ohne irgendwas. So, dann will man sich aufstürzen und will den zweiten noch schwebenden, eben noch da schwebenden Fuss zu Hilfe nehmen. Nein, auch der rutschte mir nach vorne weg und dann bin ich so schräg nach links hinten auf die Seite gefallen. Aber wie gesagt, einen dicken Daunenmantel, der hat den Schlag ein wenig abgefedert. Es hilft nicht, dass ich währenddessen auch Airpods natürlich drin hatte, wie jeder von uns. Na klar, und du auf einem Roller gefahren bist.
Und man kriegt halt es nicht so richtig mit, weil man hört es nicht, plötzlich findet man sich auf dem Boden wieder und hört währenddessen Lady Gaga.
Das ist halt, weiß ich nicht, brauche ich nicht.
Und du hast dich sofort wieder aufgerappelt oder erst mal weitergeschlittert oder wie, du hast so, ah, ich wollte eh auf dem Boden und so.
Jesus Christ, habe ich gesagt und bin dann wieder aufgestanden und gegangen. Stark. Ja, das war nicht schön, aber ja, viele Fragen. Erstens, wen kann ich verklagen? Die, es war nämlich vor einem Rewe.
Und der Rewe muss doch, und da frage ich Christian Solmecke, Anwalt von BBL. Rechtsanwalt und Partner bei WBS Lille in Köln, genau.
Da frage ich hiermit ganz direkt.
Vor einem Rewe rutschte ich aus, schlug hin, muss der Rewe nicht dafür sorgen, dass der Platz davor gestreut wird.
Wir brauchen erstmal einen Streitwert.
Wir müssen erstmal gucken, was würdest du sagen, diese Schmerzen, die du in dem Moment ja bestimmt hattest. Wie hoch... Nein, die sie ja bestimmt hatten in dem Moment, das muss ja unglaublich wehgetan haben. Wenn man eine fragile Männlichkeit dieser Frage entgegensteht, was mache ich dann? Also wir sagen mal, sie haben mir im Vertrauen gesagt, dass sie extreme Schmerzen hatten und dass sie geweint haben und dass sie danach sich tagelang nicht hinsetzen konnten und immer Aui, Aui, Aui, Aui gesagt haben, als sie sich auf ihr Sofa setzen wollten, um die Gummibärenbande zu schauen. Das waren ihre eigenen Worte. Das haben sie so zu Protokoll gegeben. Aui, Aui, Aui, mein Popo, mein Popo tut weh. Popo weh, Popo weh, Popo weh. Das würde ich jetzt in einem Streitwert von einem Schmerzgeld, sorry, ich hätte den Fall nicht annehmen dürfen. Dieser Fall macht sie krank. Dieser Fall macht sie krank. Und wenn es der letzte Fall ist, den ich abarbeiten werde, ich stehe Ihnen bei. Ich bin Christian Solmecke.
Anwalt von WBS Legal.
Er hat z.B. Partner bei WBS Legal in Köln. Und ich würde sagen, der Streitwerk liegt
bei mir bei wirklich 180.000 Euro.
180.000 Euro?
Dieser Schmerz ist 180.000 Euro wert.
Zudem die Einnahmen, die
ihnen gegangen sind, als sie
sich zu Hause in der Wohnung waren und gesagt haben,
aui, aui, aui.
Also, Rewe ist erledigt.
Das ist nämlich meine Frage.
Ich kann Rewe ausnehmen. Ich kann Rewe
... die zu Hause in der Wohnung waren und gesagt haben, aui, aui, aui. Also, Rewe ist erledigt. Das ist nämlich meine Frage. Ich glaube, ich kann Rewe ausnehmen. Ich kann Rewe ... So Rewe, wie wir es kennen, wird es bald nicht mehr geben. Aber kannst du sagen, okay, 180.000 Euro, aber nur in Rewe Guthaben? Oh, jo. Ehrlich gesagt, das ist so ein Laden, von dem würde ich das sogar annehmen, weil man kauft da, glaube, ich werde in meinem Leben noch mehr als 180.000 Euro beim Rewe lassen. Weiß ich nicht. Wie gesagt, ist das schon ein Riesenzum. Was ist dein Füllerprodukt? Also bei mir zum Beispiel, es gibt einen Supermarkt und ich brauche nichts mehr zum Einkaufen, die Einkaufsliste ist abgearbeitet. Aber ich weiss, bei dem Supermarkt gibt es was Besonderes, nämlich an der Kasse den Sunrise-Riegel.
Wir alle kennen Sunrise-Riegel.
Wir alle kennen Sunrise, die gelbe Packung, wir lieben sie, bei Aldi zum Beispiel.
Kannst du, wir kennen es alle, klar.
Puffreis, für alle, ich hole euch immer alle in die Packung.
Schön Schokolade mit Puffreis, ja, Sunrise, wie Nippon, aber noch geiler als Nippon.
Oben schön Sunrise, die Tafel, unten schauen so ein bisschen die Flocken raus, die Puffreis kommt raus. Sunrise, wir alle kennen es. Und das gibt es auch in Riegelform bei ausgewählten Supermärkten nicht allen. Dann laufe ich an dem vorbei und denke mir, so ein Sunrise-Riegel wäre schon geil. Aber ich denke mir, ich will jetzt nicht der sein, der mit 39 Jahren nur mit einem Sunrise-Riegel an der Kasse steht. Und du hast hinter mir die gestresste Mutter mit einem Wochenendeinkauf, ich habe vor mir die gestresste Mutter mit einem riesen Wochenendeinkauf und in der Mitte dazwischen, zwischen den zwei Kundendifferenzierungsmodulen, ein Sunrise-Riegel für 79 Cent. Geht nicht. Also, Füllerprodukte,
kennst du das Problem?
Selbstverständlich. Ich bin ja immer
ein Self-Checkout-Kasten, deswegen habe ich diese Probleme
nicht mehr. Wenn es sie nicht gibt,
habe ich das Problem auch.
Bin aber inzwischen auch relativ radikal.
Habe ich aber auch mal diese Fasur, dann willst du
natürlich was, was Volumen hat, finde ich.
Du willst, was aussieht wie
ah, das hat schon Sinn ergeben.
Das andere, der Sunrise-Riegel ist nur Bonus.
Deswegen immer, immer Küchentücher. Ja, ich finde auch, Küchenrollen sind die perfekte Antwort, weil voluminös und es ist kein Klopapier. Klopapier will man nicht. Nein, das ist eine ganz andere Geschichte. Klopapier ist eine ganz andere Geschichte. Das ist wie ein Notfall. Aber niemand sagt, oh, der hat gerade zu Hause einen Kaffee verschüttet und rennt jetzt los und holt sich Küchenpapier. Nee, Küchenpapier kann man immer brauchen, immer gut, saugt immer schön auf. Deswegen auch das und ... Wir empfehlen das Beste von Seva. Es gibt aber auch viele andere Produkte, die wir aber alle nicht empfehlen. Die wir eigentlich alle nicht mögen. Und ich hole auch gerne Fertignudeln. Schön so Rahmen, Bulldog, die Schafen, die Dreckschafen, die Erbärmlich-Schafen, die mir auch schon einen Pulli ruiniert haben, muss ich sagen.
Die sind so scharf, die wurden in Dänemark verboten, weil die sind so Fertigrahmen mit einer scharfen Soße.
Ich habe mir die scharfe Soße alleine in einer Flasche gekauft, leider über meinen Pulli verschüttet, Pulli musste ich wegschmeißen.
In Dänemark verboten, aber was wir nicht wissen, wegen des Spielzeugs.
Ja, das ist recht. Die Dänen haben leider kein gutes Verhältnis zum Spielzeug. Wir mögen nicht spielen, wir mögen nicht spielen, spielen, essen und spielen, ist getrennt. Du musst ja ausdrücken, ist Teil der Kultur. Ja, ich bin leider todkrank, aber weil natürlich in deren Burgen war immer der Spielraum und der Essraum strikt getrennt. Ja. Deswegen das trennen. Du kannst kein Spielzeug mehr ran. Danke, da waren wir ja noch gedanklich. Ich wollte nämlich erzählen. Bist du fertig mit deinem Sunrise? Ich bin komplett fertig. Eben wir gleich nochmal zurück müssen, also Kreuzreim. Wir gehen gleich nochmal zurück auf die Self-Checkout-Kasten, weil da haben wir viele Nachrichten bekommen. Da möchte ich in der Ruhe drüber reden. Ja, da wurden wir rangehen. Aber, genau, bei der
Burg. So, was war denn nämlich da
jetzt für ein Raum? Und der war sehr spannend.
Das war ein Aufenthaltsraum zum
Abhängen. Was hätte man da?
Also, ich glaube, die heutige Besetzung wäre
Wohnzimmer.
Also der Ort,
ja, keine Ahnung, man hat,
weiß ich auch nicht, Gäste da,
feiert oder so. Ich denke mir immer, gemütlicher wäre es, wenn man in einer kleinen Gruppe Freunde, die man da hat, wäre es am gemütlichsten, sich aufs Sofa zu setzen und da abzuhängen, ein bisschen was zu trinken und zu labern. Oft ist es der gemütlich eingerichtetste Raum, das Wohnzimmer. Lustigerweise, wenn man Gäste hat, bei mir ist es zum Beispiel so, wenn ich Freunde da habe, man ist nur am Esstisch.
Man chillt die ganze nur am Esstisch.
Man chillt die ganze Zeit am Esstisch. Und das ist irgendwie, und wie du sagst, man sagt nicht heutzutage, wollen wir nicht alle mal uns ins Wohnzimmer setzen, da ist die Reaktion oft, dass niemand zugehört hat. Ja, ja, ja, ja.
So, und das Spannende war, weil Wohnzimmer hat nämlich schon ein paar Probleme, finde ich, weil man, jetzt stellt man sich eine Couch vor, das ist eine sehr bequeme tiefe Couch, man liegt hinten drin und alle haben irgendwie Getränke oder Snacks oder so und dann gibt es diesen kleinen Couchtisch irgendwie vorne und diese Bewegung ist nicht sonderlich bequem. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Da muss man die Schüssel oft zu sich nehmen oder so. Ja, das ist schwierig.
Aber nicht jeder hat eine eigene Schüssel.
Oder man Getränke abstellen.
Ja.
Und dann muss man nach vorne, dann muss man so aufstehen. Irgendwie diese Art abzuhängen ist, glaube ich, der Grund, dass die gar nicht so gut ist. Deswegen bleibt man einfach am Esstisch sitzen, wo alle Getränke haben und man nebenbei noch was snacken kann. Ähm, und da gab's exakt das Zwischending.
Ein Tisch, der war die Mitte aus Esstisch und Couchtisch und Uralteburg. Uralteburg. Und dann gab's Stühle und die waren die Mischung aus Esstisch und so Couch. Also so schön gepolsterte, tief, aber nicht zu tief, schräg, aber nicht zu schräg, an einem Tisch gestellt, der die perfekte Höhe hatte. Und das war so ein Trinkzimmer. Geil. Man konnte sich mega gut angucken, es war super gemütlich aus und es war genau die perfekte Mischung zum Rauchen, zum Essen, zum Trinken.
Alle konnten sich angucken, es war wunderschön.
Davon habe ich ein Foto gemacht und dachte mir, das müsste man eigentlich als Möbelstück rausbringen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Es ist die Mitte aus Esszimmer und Wohnzimmer.
Jetzt haben wir gemeinhin in unseren Wohnungen nicht das Problem, dass wir zu viel Platz haben
und nicht wissen, wo wir dieses Art Zimmer haben, hat uns gerade noch gefehlt.
Ich denke mir nur, ist das Wohnzimmer überholt nicht vielleicht? In gewisser Weise schon, aber du musst natürlich es hinkriegen, nach dem Essen die Leute dahin zu verfrachten. Das ist anlockend. Essen zum Essen ist nicht gedacht, Florian. Ja, okay, deswegen meine ich ja, man trifft sich ja oft zum Essen, du bringst dein herrliches Odovre, deine Gans, deine Stopfgans und alles, bringst dir da raus.
Meine Entenstopfleber.
Stopfleber, die Ente hat so viele Lebern zum Essen bekommen, dass ihre eigene Leber geplatzt ist.
Also gibt es Wachteleier und man isst nebenbei lebende Oktopusse.
Richtig.
Du warst schon mal bei mir.
Ja, das ist lecker, wirklich köstlich.
Und dann aber das Problem, man hängt fest am Tisch und man bräucht natürlich eine starke Stimme, die sagt, so und jetzt gehen wir zu dem leicht tieferen Tisch.
Vielen Dank. Köstlich. Und dann aber das Problem, man hängt fest am Tisch und man bräucht natürlich eine starke Stimme, die sagt, so und jetzt gehen wir zu dem leicht tieferen Tisch mit den Stühlen, die leicht mehr geneigt sind. Ist natürlich nicht so der Anziehungsfaktor, wo du jetzt sagst, da muss ich unbedingt hin. Ich sagte eins, dieser Tisch, der zieht automatisch die Leute an. Leute, nach dem Essen werden die, wie automatisch, wie unsere, die menschliche Natur treibt einen dann zu dieser Art Tisch.
Sind wir da aber technologisch nicht schon weiter, könnten wir da nicht sagen, okay, Essen ist vorbei und dann gibt es ja diesen Zurücklehnen, Gürtel auf, momentan so, und dann haut jemand auf den Knopf und dann der Tisch fährt runter, die Stühle fahren nach hinten und ab dann gibt es aber auch kein Zurück mehr. Und zwar machen wir das dann so, das muss niemand mal machen, die Uhrzeit, es ist ein Tisch, der je nach Uhrzeit automatisch die Position ändert, also je später die Stunde, das ist das Problem, wenn man sehr lange das Essen hat, dann rutscht man nach hinten. Das ist sogar ein stufenloser Prozess. Im Laufe des Abends. Am Ende ist der Tisch ganz unten und alle liegen am Boden und wissen gar nicht, wie sie da hingekommen sind. Und mir wurden zweimal die Knie gebrochen. Du schläfst und du wirst erst morgens von dem ruhigen Aufsitzen geweckt, weil sich alle wieder aufrichten und plötzlich am gedeckten Frühstückstisch sitzen. Aber das ist wirklich an der Zeitschaltuhr gekoppelt und der Tisch fährt langsam zurück und die sich verlehrt. Ich fände das sehr gut, ich fände das wirklich sehr gut.
Das sollte man etablieren, weil dann hast du
nicht dieses Problem, dieses autoritäre, wir müssen woanders
hin, sondern es fährt die ganze Zeit runter.
Und du kannst natürlich auch sagen,
die Party läuft schlecht
und dann hast du als Host, hast du ein
Kontrollzentrum, wo du reingehst und dann
sitzen da so fünf Leute vor so Monitoren, die
alles überwachen, biep, biep, biep, biep, und alles ist da und dann sagst du, scheiße, Leute, läuft nicht, wir haben ein Problem bei Agathe, Agathe kommt irgendwie erst nicht mit ihren dummen Themen hier rein, interessiert niemand Kunstthemen und so, ähm, Faktor 1,3, und dann kannst du nämlich die Beschleunigung erhöhen, fallen lassen, raus, ja, Falltür, Und wir müssen raus, wir sind nicht in der Zeit,
Faktor 1,3 und dann wird alles 30% schneller.
Die Musik.
Das heißt, die Musik wird schneller,
die Gespräche werden schneller, mehr Luft im Raum
und der Tisch fährt schneller runter.
Dann kannst du alles so ein bisschen anpassen, wie du willst.
Weil das ist ja auch das Problem, dass du oft denkst,
der Abend lang und gemütlich
und dann merkst du nach 10 Minuten, fuck,
ich habe hier ganz unangenehme Leute bei mir irgendwie, warum sind das meine Freunde und kriegst sie nicht los, weil alles schon geplant ist. Generell merke ich auch, ich bin ein viel besserer Gast als ein Gastgeber. Ich bin mit dem Wissen, dass ich nach Hause kann gleich, dass ich jeden Zeitpunkt nach Hause kann, macht mich zu einem viel entspannteren Menschen. Das glaube ich wirklich. Ich bin ja oft in so sozialen Settings der Fahrer, weil ich keinen Alkohol trinke. Der Feind eigentlich. Und ich mag diese Rolle sehr gern, weil du bist so ein bisschen außen vor. Die Leute erwarten gar nicht, dass du Spaß hast. Aber wie ist es für dich, dass du beobachtest, wie Leute langsam, du hast glaube ich einen besseren Blick auf die Droge Alkohol, auf die Alltagsdroge Alkohol, als ich jetzt zum Beispiel, weil du Leuten damit zuguckst, wie sie langsam aggressiver werden, ruhiger werden, müder werden, aber mehr reden, sich lockerer sind. Ja, die Gesangsstimme kommt raus. Ihr habt damit überhaupt kein Problem, aber man ist natürlich sehr Beobachter, man ist so ein bisschen außen vor, weil die Leute erwarten gar nicht, dass man Spaß hat, weil du bist so ein bisschen der Chauffeur, du bist wie der Diener, der sich mit dem Gesicht zur Wand dreht, wenn der Graf in den Raum kommt und du sagst, ich bin gar nicht da, das Problem ist natürlich nur, du kannst nicht vor den anderen gehen, weil du musst ja noch nach Hause fahren, das heißt, du bist wirklich auf Gedeih und Verderb gebunden an diese Leute, die stockbesoffen irgendwo liegen und sagen, hey, wir fahren nochmal zum Hauptbahnhof und denkst dir, das wird nochmal ewig dauern, Hauptbahnhof ist super weit weg und du bist daran gebunden. Das ist natürlich das Problem. Sagst du dann, weil das glaube ich nämlich nicht, dass du es machst, ich frage die Frage trotzdem, sagst du dann, nee, es ist ja Zeit nach Hause zu gehen. Ja, doch, probiere ich schon. Also ich bin mittlerweile mit der Zeit da selbstbewusster geworden. Ich haue da auf den Tisch und sage, nee, Leute, jetzt reicht es auch. Und so, weil es gibt in der Gruppe schon immer so ein paar Leute, die dann auch so Anzeichen machen, so, ich muss ja morgen früh raus und so. Ah ja, okay, dann sollten wir ihm zugehen. Ah ja, sofern! Ah ja, lass uns losfahren, lass sofort. Aber dann gibt es natürlich Leute, die dagegen ankämpfen, es ist schwierig. Aber das ist so meine Dynamik eigentlich immer bei solchen Gelagen. Ja, spannend. Ich habe dieses Möbelstück gesehen, diese Art Dessel, für die es gar kein Wort gibt, Lounge Chairs vielleicht am ehesten. Dass man dann so immer weiter runterfährt. Ach, Chairs long, du kannst doch rumliegen, glaube ich nicht. Aber so Lounge Chairs und Lounge Tisch wäre es vielleicht am ehesten, ich habe lange darüber nachgedacht. Aber dieser Couchtisch, wie wir ihn kennen, dieser flache Tisch, ist wirklich überholt, finde ich.
Der erfüllt nicht den Zweck eines Tisches.
Es ist ein Ablagebalken, der sehr tief ist.
Es ist komisch, dass die Couch die Leute eigentlich auseinanderzieht.
Je mehr du dich nach hinten lehnst, desto mehr werden die Leute auseinandergezogen
und desto schwerer wird der Griff in die Flipsschüssel.
Und ich denke auch den ganzen Abend, fuck, ich hätte mich näher an die Lakritze setzen sollen. Die Lakritze ist ganz weit weg. Wenn ich jetzt sage, Lakritze, mehr zu mir, dann muss ich was hergeben, dann muss ich die Oreos hergeben. Und du willst dir nicht die Blöße geben, zu sagen, ich kann nicht wie die Lakritze haben. Aber auch spannend, eine Freundin von mir, mit der wir damals immer viel abends bei der wir oft waren, die hat in so einem uralten Gebäude gewohnt, die hatte so eine alte Mühle und die hatte so ein alten Mühlengebäude und das war wirklich noch so uralt, also irgendwie so sechzehnt. Jahrhunderts-Style, und da gab es auch so ein Kaminzimmer und da gab es so spannend wirklich eingebaute Einbausessel. Also es gab einen Kamin, der war mitten im Raum. Und dann gab es da rum eingebaute, eingelassene Sitzmöbel mit, da könnte man ein Polster drauflegen. Und dann hatte jeder so einen eigenen Sessel im Kreis herum um diesen Kamin. Die man nicht bewegen konnte. Die man nicht bewegen konnte, wo noch genug Platz war, um durchzugehen und sich seinen Sessel zu nehmen, ohne dass die anderen irgendwie aufstehen müssen oder so. Und jeder hatte so eine eigene Ablage, auch alles so geschnitzt, so mit Mustern, Ablage für Getränk und dann jeder hat noch einen eigenen Aschenbecher. Okay. Der wurde dann nicht mehr benutzt, natürlich, weil drinnen rauchen, nein, aber das war wirklich etwas, wo ich dachte, ja, crazy, es ist komplett abhandengekommen, dass man so selbstbewusst sagt, weil das ist ja jetzt auch, ich glaube, das ist jetzt auch nicht so normal. Ich glaube, da hat sich jemand überlegt, der damalige Schreiner, Zimmermann, was auch immer. Weiß ich auch nicht genau, was Tischler, Schreiner und Zimmermann der Unterschied ist. Ja, keine Ahnung. Aber irgendwer in that realm hat gesagt, ich habe eine Idee und hat es gebaut. Du musst dir schon sehr, sehr sicher um dein soziales Umfeld sein, weil, sagen wir mal, das sind acht Sitze, die da fest sind. Und jetzt kommst du da mit einer Gruppe rein, zu neunt. Und jetzt ist natürlich so Reise nach Jerusalem, aber man nimmt sich und einer ist einfach übrig. Und also du kannst, stellst du dann noch einen Stuhl, holst dir ran oder setzt dich auf die Lehne oder dieser Raum sagt dir einfach, du bist überflüssig, du bist hier nicht erwünscht. Wie schrecklich ist das denn?
Marco, kommst du mal bitte raus? Kommst du mal kurz bitte? Ich will draus mit dir sprechen. Was denn? Coole Party übrigens, richtig cooles Haus. Warum hast du Lena mitgebracht? Wir sind jetzt zu neunt, wir kommen nicht in meine Sitzecke. Ich habe neun kleine Fernseher, ich habe neun, ich habe acht Fernseher, acht Drinks. Aber Lena ist doch cool, ich meine ist meine neue Freundin und ich dachte, ich bin sehr... Ich habe nur acht Sitze, die automatisch gemessen an die Zeitschaltruhe runterfahren. Scheiße, tu mal leise, dann gehe ich, okay, dann gehe ich. Nein, ich kenne die nicht mal. Wer weiss, was sie isst. Das ist Lena. Wer weiss, was sie isst. Wer weiss, was sie snacken will. Sie sitzt einfach auf meiner, auf der Seite, auf. Du glaubst, wirkliches Leben ist so einfach und du kannst immer alles einfach spontan entscheiden und wie du gerade Bock hast. Ja, aber ich muss auch mal die Frage stellen, warum hast du nur acht Sitze beim Schreiner Schuster Steinmitz in Auftrag gegeben? Du wusstest doch, dass es mit Lena und mir ernster wird. Du wusstest doch genau, dass unser Freundeskreis besteht aus Leuten und ich gerade irgendwie mit Lena texte. Du musst mir Bescheid sagen und dann muss ich... Ich habe doch gesagt, es läuft gut mit uns. Dann muss ich Wilhelm rauswerfen. Drei Herzen, bist du bescheuert? Drei Herzen, ich habe dir die Nachricht gezeigt. Das schreit doch nach einem Schreiner. Also ist auch ein bisschen deine Schuld. Schmeiss Markus raus. Markus. Warum Markus?
Fahrer, komm mal.
Wir brauchen keinen Fahrer, wir haben eine Kutsche.
Naja, aber er haut immer so auf den Tisch irgendwann und sagt, dass es Zeit ist.
Ja, wir brauchen das auch ein bisschen, das stimmt schon.
Ja, auch nervig, aber ja, wir brauchen was.
Wollen wir nochmal die Sarazenen angreifen?
Und dann kommt der Schreiner und baut noch einen Tisch, Stuhlsessel dran. Aber es ist auch so schlimm, wenn du ja zu siebt bist und dann ist so ein Sitz leer und zwei Leute müssen sich immer über diesen toten Sitz, wo noch so für die verstorbene Mutter auch gedeckt ist, so ganz komisch müssen sich immer, ist es jetzt respektlos
über den leeren Sitz zu kommunizieren?
Darf man sich da kurz reinsetzen?
Ich habe gehört, ihr redet gerade über Herr der Ringe.
Übrigens, ich setze mich mal kurz zu euch.
Maura la Bingi, das wird euch wahrscheinlich nicht sagen.
Aber so, und dann musst du dir hin und her pendeln.
Da sitzt eigentlich die Mutter.
Boah, das ist so ein unangenehmer Move
in so einer Situation,
wenn sich jemand wegsetzt und du ganz alleine bist. und die einzige Person, mit der dich unterhalten konnte, hat sich von dir weggesetzt und du, ach, das ist wirklich. Ja, das stimmt, da spricht man was an, weil jeder hat ja diese Ablage wie im Kino, wo man das so reinstecken kann, so ein Drink oder so. Genau, ja. Und das sieht halt sofort weird aus, wenn dann nur, ich weiß nicht, eins weniger, sieben Leute da sitzen. Ja. Dann ist es total komisch, weil dann ist da so der Drink leer, ist einfach traurig sofort. Unfassbar unangenehm, ey. Aber das wäre ja sofort meine Sketch-Serie bei solchen Ritterdingern. Da hätte ich ja Bock drauf, so eine Mittelalter-Sketch-Serie, dass du da so was machst und dann wirklich mit den acht Schreinern wer kommt, hat der sich jetzt noch mal irgendwie eine Burgdame geraubt oder nicht oder was kommt da, ist es ernst mit den beiden und so und dann hast du diese Irrenverstrickungen. Das sind diese Irrenverstrickungen und Irrungen und Wirrungen. Aber ja, ich finde das sehr spannend und rege jetzt an, selbstbewusst mal wieder zu gucken, wir alle lieben Ikea, klar, wir kaufen unseren Kram. Ikea, Möbelkraft, Xxxxlux, Xxxlux, Xxxlux. Ach Gott, fangen wir nicht mit Xxxlux an. Ich meine ... Schon die kleinen Luchse sind ein gross genuges Problem. Aber wir lassen uns so ein bisschen auch von denen aufoktroyieren, was wir da für Möbel haben, was wir hinstellen. Ja, can we move on? Die Möbelerlebniswelt. Ja, genau, ich glaube, wir haben genug genannt. Also nach den ersten drei haben wir, glaube ich, genug genannt. Ich liebe Aufzählungen. Ich mag Aufzählungen. Möbel Zurbürgen bei mir in Unna war ganz toll. So ganz viele. Aber wir können auch selber mal wieder in den Baumarkt gehen und uns einfach eine Platte holen. Und wie gesagt, wir haben schon wichtig genug, ja, Hornbach, Bauhaus, hey, Hammer, so, und dann kannst du die alle, kannst du kaufen und dann bau dir doch selber, wie du dein Freundeskreis, ich kenne doch euren Freundeskreis am besten. Klar, der Ferdinand, Rudolf, Carsten. Brauchst nicht alle aufzählen! Aber weißt du, was ich meine? Wir zum Beispiel, wie wir da immer dann sitzen. Stefan, Florentin. Wir hören dann den Wagner. Wagner, Beethoven, Bachel, Mozart, ja. Nein, aber ihr könnt genau gucken gucken, was ihr braucht und dann baut euch die Möbel
dementsprechend. Ich finde das sehr gut, ich finde das
richtig gut und dann vor Planen
und dann aber auch eine Feedback-Runde zu sagen, hat euch der
Abend, war der euch zu schnell, war der zu langsam,
soll man nochmals anpassen am Koeffizienten?
Ich glaube, ich wäre dann der, der Lust hätte, genau
an diesem Koeffizienten zu schrauben, der das
Ganze nochmal so zwei Prozent beschleunigt, vier Prozent
langsamer, ein bisschen schneller.
Ja. Ein bisschen schneller, langsamer, ein bisschen seitlich, ein bisschen drüber. Ich schaue ja gerne Kulturveranstaltungen und da mag ich immer, wenn Leute aufgezählt werden. Dieses konstante Name-Gedroppe. Ich habe letztens eine Kulturveranstaltung gesehen mit Harfe, mit einer Harfinistin, die war da und dann hast du natürlich auch immer so einen Hausensasser. Für uns durch, was für eine Kulturveranstaltung warst du? Es ist so eine klassische Kulturveranstaltung Du hast immer so einen da sitzen so Olli Schluckrohr oder so, er ist Autor, er ist alles dreht sich nur um Aufzählungen, er ist Autor er ist DJ, er ist Schauspieler Ulli, sag's uns, was kannst du eigentlich nicht? Das Wort Tausendsassa. Ja, ganz folgt. Das möchte ich gerade eigentlich versprechen, egal was nochmal mit uns passiert, wenn wir später eingeladen werden, die grossen Sendungen oder sowas. Mein Versprechen ist, wenn das Wort, wenn bei mir das Wort Tausendsassa fällt, stehe ich auf und gehe. Ja, absolut. Das Jahr 2025 ist
ich rufe das Jahr
der Effizienz aus. Wir haben keine Zeit
mehr. Es sind wilde Zeiten. Wir haben keine Zeit
für Quatsch. Schneller. Wenn jemand dich
tausend Sasser benennt,
musst du das Gespräch verlassen. Du bist Autor,
du bist DJ, du bist Schauspieler,
jetzt machst du auch noch Musik.
Uli Schluckspecht, du bist ein Hansdampf
in allen Gassen. Herzlich willkommen. Und jetzt bringst du auch noch dein erstes Buch raus? Ja, völlig richtig, genau. Ich bringe mein Buch raus. Was kannst du eigentlich nicht? Halt deinen Dosen im Auge. Und ich mag dann auch immer, wenn dann so genamedroppt wird, aber von Leuten, die kein Mensch kennt. Einfach so, ich weiß ja noch, wo wir früher am Leibnitzer Staatstheater waren, Uli Friedl, Agathe Knosper, Arne Freidel, Karl-Heinz Moskel, Biene Breidel. Es war konstant ein endloser Strom an Namen, die niemand kennt. Man kann irgendwas sagen, aber es ist immer mit einer solchen, und ja klar, Uli Frettenbach, Vanessa Kriegel, Signorita Caloni, Mainz-Schmeck, Hans Schwedenkm, Arne Hitler, ich meine die ganzen Leute, da ist immer irgendwas parat. Tausend Leute und der Zuschauer sind einfach da, kennt niemanden. Niemanden. Aber weißt du was, manchmal geht es auch einfach darum, also bei mir auch häufig, das Gefühl, dass man gerade etwas hört oder konsumiert, was einen weiterbringt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es dieser Gegenentwurf zu TikTok ist, so eine komplette Verstreuung, dass ich die ganze Zeit auch gerne sowas höre, was mir das Gefühl gibt, ich bin Teil eines erlesenen Kreises, ich tue was für mich, und auch wenn ich das alles nicht unbedingt verstehe, bin ich froh, dabei zu sein. Ich finde es schlimmer, das nicht zu hören, als diese Aufzählung von Leuten, die ich nicht kenne. Man hat auch dieses Gefühl des Networkings, es sind alle da, es werden alle ins Boot geholt. Es war Manfred Weselgrund, Henriette Schneckelbach, Zoe Swerbel, Kronweimbel und dann immer dieses Ach ja, der ja auch noch, Hans Glombel, Arne Spockbotz, alle mit dabei. Ja, und Maike Fromm. Maike Fromm, natürlich, klar, die ganze Leipziger Schule, Maike Fromm, Olli Diensten, Fred Greimel, Ormsomble. Ja, Winhardt Bomse, Winhardt. Ich glaube, ich mache mir mal einen Nachmittag frei und schneide aus allen Kultursendungen diese Aufzählungen, nur diese Aufzählungen ineinander, dass du wirklich so ein stundenlanges Video hast, nur Namen, Namen, Namen, Namen, Namen, Namen, Namen, Namen, Namen. Grossartig. Ich will auch mal genannt werden in sowas. Ich glaube, du wurdest bestimmt schon mal genannt. Vielleicht würde ich, kann sein. Das ist die große Gruppe, die aus der ganzen Böhmermannschen Schule herauf vorgegangen ist. Jan Böhmermann, Oli Schulz, Felix Lobrecht, Patrick Stenzel, Julia Becker, Chris Sommer, Takan Baci, Miguel Rubitski, Larissa Ries, Karina Gerz, Dendemann. Mir fallen in diesem Moment gar nicht diese ganzen Namen ein. Mir auch nicht, deswegen habe ich so Respekt vor den Leuten, die teilweise wirklich 30, 40 Namen einfach wasserfallartig runterbeten und man sich denkt, wer soll hier reinkommen in dieses Programm? Ich war neulich auf so einem Networking-Event und dann kam jemand zu mir und ich wusste auch, wer es war und von welchem Projekt ich den kenne. Und dann waren in dem Kreis, er hat sich dazugestellt, in dem Kreis waren auch ein paar engere Freunde von mir und die haben dann so erwartungsvoll geguckt, ah, wer ist der Mann, der gerade gekommen ist, erklär uns, wer das ist.
Und ich wusste sowohl, von welchem Projekt, von welcher Firma er kommt, ich wusste diese ganzen Sachen grob in meinem Kopf, aber was nicht gut vernetzt war an dem Abend, vielleicht auch weil diese ganzen Network Events irgendwie auch den Kopf von innen aushöhlen, wie so ein Löffel, so ein Wassereis, Milcheis, Kratzeis, genau, ist mir nichts eingefallen, nichts, I had nothing. Und dann die so, ja, wer ist das? Das ist ja von und wir haben doch dieses, und mir ist weder Name, Projekt noch eingefallen, wo wir das gemacht haben. Shit.
Wirklich kein Projektname, es war gar nichts mehr da.
Die Produktionsfilme war weg, es war alles weg.
Und Gott sei Dank war das so laut.
Gott sei Dank war das so laut und ich hab dann so, du weißt doch.
Man kann es vernuscheln.
Hab ich es vernuschelt, aber hab ich es vernuschelt. Ja, das war das so, wir haben doch zusammen. Und es war nicht, das muss ich an der Stelle betonen, Unhöflichkeit oder Ignoranz, es war tatsächlich einfach diese Synapse, die verbindet mein Gehirn mit meinem Erinnerungsareal komplett weg. Keine Knicks. Und ich hatte wirklich absolut gar nichts. Da musst du halt zurückfallen auf so allgemeinen Plätze wie, ah, du alte Hundelunge, du alter, ah, der Meister hier. Schluckspecht. Du alter Schluckspecht, so irgendwie sowas, wo alle auch verstehen. Unverfänglich. Weil das muss ich auch sagen, da nehme ich jetzt tatsächlich auch deine sogenannten Freunde an die Kandare. Das ist ein Move, den macht man nicht. Dieses Stell uns doch mal vor, das macht man nicht. Das finde ich ist unhöflich. Weil wenn du ihn vorstellen willst, mach es, aber man muss Raum offen halten für der Typ hat keine Ahnung, welche gerade, ich meine, sagen wir mal ehrlich, du bist Stefan Tietze. Hm, ja, was meinst du damit jetzt genau? Ja, ich meine, du bist Stefan Tietze. Wie viele Leute kennst du? Max Bierhals, Takan Badji, Christian Huber, Julia Becker. Julia Becker. Du kennst so viele Leute, da kann man nicht erwarten, dass du da jeden dahergelaufenen Regieassistenten auch noch kennst.
Das war wirklich sehr unangenehm. Ich glaube, es kam vom Sturz. Rückblickend, seitdem ich da hingeschlagen bin, wusste ich, dieses war nicht mehr ein Gedächtnisteil, der mir nicht mehr zugänglich war. Ja, aber so ist es und ich finde, da muss man auch wirklich gesellschaftliche Geflogenheiten bewahren. Finde ich auch gut, aber wirklich, wenn ihr in so einer Gruppe seid, macht nicht den, ah, wer ist das denn, stell uns doch mal vor, mach es einfach nicht. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Mach es einfach nicht, im Gegenteil, wenn da jemand Neues dazukommt, frag ihn, ah, wer bist du denn, was willst du denn hier, wer hat dich denn gefragt, sowas. Stefan kann uns bestimmt vorstellen, wir haben noch lange zusammengearbeitet. Okay, gut. hat es auch ein bisschen mit sozial feindliche Seligkeit. Es gab mal tatsächlich bei Rocket Beans einen sehr unsympathischen Mitarbeiter. Spill it, fucking spill it. Florentin spills the tea, fucking leaks, leaks. Ihr wollt die juicy Sachen, ihr habt sie, ihr habt die. Okay, kommt rein, kommt rein, aber sagt's nicht weiter, ne, kommt mal nah ran. Ja, okay, ich spiel euch jetzt mal was. Wir wollen Namen. Ein sehr unsympathischer Mitarbeiter, der sich zur Belustigung immer gemacht hat, zu jemandem zu gehen, wenn gerade irgendwie neuer Praktikant oder so da war und die Person dann gefragt hat, ah, wer ist das denn, wie heißt der denn? Oh mein Gott. Und die Person dann das nicht wusste. Und ich bin dem einige Male zum Opfer gefallen. Das ist wirklich unangenehm, weil ja, man kann das natürlich immer so lustig machen, praktikanten werden schlecht behandelt, das ist so ein Running Gag, eigentlich immer, wenn man mit der Praktikanten redet, aber wenn die Person dann vor dir steht und du auch weißt, der hat sich vorgestellt. Es ist so, es muss ein Schleier des Schweigens über solche Sachen einfach gehüllt werden. Und wir müssen alle zusammenarbeiten, dass dieser Schleier des Schweigens fest ist. Ja, es ist wie in der Burg, da gab es nämlich diesen Geheimgang nach draußen. Ich glaube, man nennt es auch Fuchsloch. Okay. Weiß ich nicht genau. Da dachte ich, vielleicht weiss du mehr. Lieber Füchse als Luchse.
Foxhole ist eigentlich ein Schützengraben,
so ein Schützengrabenloch. Ja, stimmt eigentlich. Aber irgendwie, da war so ein
kleiner Gang aus der
Burg raus, aus dem Stadtbau raus
und da stand Fuchsloch drüber. Vielleicht
stimmt's auch nicht, aber
es gab diesen Gang nach draußen,
diesen Geheimgang, und den braucht
man gesellschaftlich immer.
Für, du brauchst nämlich
gesellschaftlich
Vielen Dank. Ich glaube, diesen Gang nach draußen, diesen Geheimgang, und den braucht man gesellschaftlich immer. Für, du brauchst nämlich gesellschaftlich, wieso sagst du, ah, in solchen Situationen musst du das nämlich erhalten. Du musst Leuten die Möglichkeit geben, sich rauszuwieseln. Ach, die gehen, die wieseln sich raus, die füchseln sich raus, hätte man früher gesagt. Ja, oder? Du musst nämlich, wenn der Partikant, du weißt den Namen nicht, alle wissen das. Ja, ja, ja. Obwohl es alle wissen, einen Riesenunterschied, dich auszucallen und zu sagen, wie heißt der denn? Weil das Ausgesprochene ist, das Reale ist, wir Menschen sind so fähig zu lügen, wir sind so fähig, dass, obwohl alle gerade wissen, was Sache ist und so. Ich meine auch so diese Frage, warum willst du mich nicht mehr treffen? Es gibt manche Menschen, die sagen so nach so einem zweiten Date oder so, warum willst du mich denn nicht mehr sehen? Und man denkt sich so, nein, das ist keine Frage, die man stellt. Nee, das geht nicht, das verboten. Und natürlich, alles Gelaber ist irgendwie Bullshit, wie zum Beispiel ich hab's bei uns nicht so richtig gefühlt, ah irgendwie. Ich muss mich auf mein Studium konzentrieren. Genau, das ist alles Bullshit. Und das ist auch allen klar, dass es Bullshit ist. Es wird nicht die Wahrheit gesagt, weil die Wahrheit verletzt. Es ist ein gesellschaftliches Recht, belogen zu werden. Als Teil der Gesellschaft hast du das Recht, zu lügen und belogen zuogen zu werden. In manchen Situationen. Dann nicht zu lügen, wäre ein Gesellschaftsbruch. Aber lustigerweise, und das verstehe ich wirklich nicht so ganz, ist das eine verletzen, das andere nicht. Wenn ich geghostet werde nach einem zweiten Date, denke ich mir schon, sie will mich wahrscheinlich nie mehr treffen. Wenn man dann fragt und sie sagt, die Wahrheit würde mich trotzdem verletzen, obwohl ich schon alles weiß, das ist so crazy, man ist dann clever, aber doch dumm als Mensch, weil der Praktikant, dessen Namen du nicht weißt, bei der Frage, wie heißt der, weiss der Praktikant schon, dass du es nicht sagen kannst, weil er geht davon aus, er weiss, der hat meinen Namen, ich habe mich einmal vorgestellt, ich bin kurz erst gleich, ich bin gestern hier, aber sobald du sagst, ich weiß es nicht mehr, ich glaube, die Verletzung ist trotzdem da, plötzlich hast du so ein Vakuum im Raum, ja, ist richtig unangenehm. Leute brauchen wirklich dieses, ja, Menschen sind einfach so, Menschen reden in Code, Menschen reden mit Ausflüchten, und wenn du die wegnimmst, dann ist die soziale Chaos. Alles weg, alles weg. Das geht nicht. Boah, du hast mir vor der ... Ich habe mir auch so einen Schluck gegönnt, Hustensaft aus New York. Boah, der ist schon ganz schön hart. Wie ist es denn, wenn du Hustensaft trinkst, ohne Husten zu haben? Kriegst du denn Husten? Also ist es Minus Minus oder wie ist es? Es geht so vor den Kopf rein. Was heißt das? Geht sofort in den Kopf und benedelt meinen Kopf. Und ich denke mir, wow, du hast so schöne Augen. Okay, verstehe. Ja, oder im dimmen Gehirn denkt man jetzt, ja, aber wir haben gar keinen Husten. Ich check's nicht. Was gibt er uns? Also wie, warum gibt er uns Husten? Was will er uns sagen? Es ist ein Zeichen. Er will uns warnen. Will er uns Husten? Will er nicht sein, mit uns zu turnen? Husten, H-U-S-T-E-S-Wordel? Das könnte Wordel sein, ja, ja. Das könnte Wordel sein. Ist das so ein Hilferuf oder so? Sollen wir rennen? Husten, Hustle. Ich meine, das letzte Mal, als wir gerannt sind, sind wir hingeschlagen. Wir sind richtig hingeschlagen. Richtig fucking hingeschlagen. Und dann hat er gesagt, oh, mein Popo tut weh, ich habe Popo weh. Aua, Auaua, Popo wie, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, o einfach, ich frage mich immer, wie das ist, weil das war ja die Zeit, bevor richtig gross Gewürze gehandelt wurden und so, Überseehandel und so.
Was ist, wenn du zu so einem wirklich krassen Königin gehst,
der jeden Tag Festmahl hat und du gibst ihm so ein richtig geiles
so ein Yes-Törtchen.
Aber so ein Schoko-Yes-Törtchen.
Der hat ja noch nie Schokolade gegessen.
Kuchen wird's wahrscheinlich mit Früchten,
ja diese kleinen Riegelkuchen.
Diese so eingeschweißt,
diese kleinen Yes-Törtchen. Yes! Also bestimmt schon mal gesehen an der kleinen, an der bekommst du das mit den Sachen an, den ich nicht kenne? Ja, weil du keinen Snack. Stefan Tietze, der einmal öffentlich verlautbaren hat, lassen, ich mag keine Desserts. Wenn ich denke, also wirklich Ja, zehn Kilo später würde ich sagen, sag ich gerade, ja, ich liebe Snacks. Ich bin ein Riesensnack-Fan. Ich baue damit gerade alles rein. Geile, diese Schnüre. Oh, die sind geil. Je unnatürlicher die Farbe, desto blau, desto besser. Die mag ich sehr, diese Schnüre sind total lecker. Wenn du mal so einen, wirklich so einen König, so einen Richard dem Zweiten, wenn du dem diese Schnüre gibst, wenn du dem diese Schnüre gibst, sagt der, ach so, ja, schmeckt ja wie ein Apfel ungefähr. Oder sagt der, what the, holy shit, was ist das? Ich glaube, mit Zucker kannst du diese Kultur da niederreißen, als Zeitreisender. Manche Dinge, glaube ich, die zerficken dir hier, wie zum Beispiel Star Wars. Du bringst den Laptop mit und zeigst den Star Wars. Hentai, ja. Wahrscheinlich. Ja, also wollen wir noch mal der Pate sehen? Nee, ich würde noch mal gern diese edle Maid mit den Tentakeln, mit dem Fisch. Unterleib, mit dem oktopalen Unterleib. Ja, mein Lord. Jawohl, mein Lord. Und dann fand ich super, hat der uns bei der Bookführung viele Sachen erklärt, wie zum Beispiel im Schilde führen. Waffe im Schilde. Genau, dann wusste ich von dir sehr viele Sachen, konnte ich brillieren. Warum gab es Wendeltreppen und keinen richtigen? Das fiel mir natürlich ein, auch im Verteidigungsfall einfacher, warum gehen die so rum und nicht so rum. Das ist mittlerweile leider sogar ein bisschen widerlegt worden. Ja, guck mal, ich hätte das neue Flotien-Update nicht bekommen. Es gibt auch Burgen, die andersrum gedreht werden. Wenn die Burg so weit gefallen ist, dass die die Treppe hochgehen, ist eh schon ein Problem. Aber mag sein, dass vielleicht bei manchen Burgen man sich das gedacht hat, dass die Wetteltreppe sich so dreht, dass der, der oben steht, mit seinem Scherzarm noch schwingen kann,
wohingegen der untere, der Angreifer,
höchstwahrscheinlich in dem Fall behindert ist.
Aber nehmt das nicht von mir, geht ins
Internet, recherchiert das ordentlich.
Ja, recherchiert das aus und
nehmt die nicht irgendwie Wissen von uns mit.
Genau, Rewe, Self-Checkout-Kassen,
dieses ganze Thema hat eine Menge...
Lass uns da noch eine Schnur dran machen.
Eine Gummischnur. Ich fand das sehr spannend, das war so polarisierend. Ja, ja, die Leute haben dich richtig herangenommen an die Kandare. Ja, ich finde, die haben dich herangenommen an die Kandare. Die haben dich voll den Kandaren gespannt. Wissen wir beide nicht, was eine Kandare ist? Vielleicht können wir uns darauf ja einigen. Nee, es ist so ein ... Dass man, wenn man schnell ... Nee, einer hat geschrieben, was für Freunde hat Stefan eigentlich die regelmäßig am Self-Checkout klauen. Jetzt rechtfertige dich mal. Wasserklauen. Ja, wir sind ja erstmal, sei das rüber, über allem steht ja, wir sind ein Comedy-Podcast. So, unter, unter Kategorie. Verbrechen sind für dich also lustig. Okay, dann haben wir es ja dann haben wir es ja verstanden. Gesetze zu brechen ist also lustig. Na dann, dann haben wir es doch verstanden. Und dann habe ich auch keine weiteren Fragen.
Ja, du hast deine Klaukategorie vorgestellt. Unterhaltsam fand ich schon. Fünf müsste ich sagen, es war rückblickend ernst, purer Ernst, das weiß ich nicht. Jedenfalls muss ich sagen, ich finde es sehr interessant, wie viele dann dachten und ernsthaft die Meinung vertreten haben, dass wenn man klaut, dass die Kunden bestraft werden. Das finde ich eine super spannende Sache. Weil die Preise dann hochgehen und die anderen mehr zahlen müssen. Als wären das so eine erziehungsberechtigten Supermarktketten.
Und dann wird da viel geklaut und dann sagt man, oh gut, dann nehmen wir jetzt das viel weg.
Wir nehmen das wieder alles weg.
Wir verkaufen jetzt keine M&Ms mehr. Als wäre das ein reiner Servicegedanke, der dahinter steckt. Sag mal, hakt's? Das ist doch kein Servicegedanke, dass die arme Kassiererin der arme Kassierer ausgetauscht wird. Das ist nicht, damit ihr nicht mit Leuten kommunizieren müsst, sondern weil es fucking billiger ist. Wenn man dabei klaut und das wird weggenommen, dann ist es eine betriebswirtschaftliche Antwort darauf. Und nicht, weil man euch bestrafen will. Das finde ich so lustig, dass die netten Konzerne, es ist so, es ist überhaupt nicht angekommen, dass die in ihrem eigenen Interesse handeln, und zwar die ganze Zeit. Und vermutlich ist es so viel billiger für die, diese Sache zu nehmen. Die nehmen das in Kauf, alles, was geklaut wird. Die wissen auch am allerbesten, wie viel geklaut wird. Das ist doch klar. Du kannst dir mal überlegen, was ist der Stundenlohn von einem Kassierer? Ich bin eine Stunde lang im Supermarkt, wie viel darf ich dann klauen? Easy. Kann man ausrechnen. Es ist insane, und das fand ich wirklich super spannend.
Wir nehmen uns das alles wieder weg,
vielen Dank an euch. Wegen dir sind die M&M's so toll, Stefan.
Ja, genau.
Weil wir, die, die, die
bei Self-Checkout-Kassen
mal die Airways-Packung
mitnehmen,
gehen lassen, die sind dafür schuld
an der Inflation. Das weiß ja, das weiß jedes Kind. Ja, ich bin gespannt, was da jetzt wieder für Kommentare drauf kommen. Stefan legt sich da an, aber ich bin sehr gespannt und ich werde dir da auch die geteilt. Ja, wiesel dich da raus. Stefan legt sich da an. Vielen Dank, Florentin. Gut, du bist krank, du musst dich da nicht in die Bresche. Oh, du kannst dir auch opfern. Du kannst dir auch opfern. Nee, ich bin da total bei dir und mir wurden noch einige Reels geschickt von Leuten, die erwischt wurden an Self-Checkout-Kassen und die dann wirklich mit Überwachungskamera denen gezeigt wurde, hat der es wirklich drübergezogen, ist es sozusagen glaubwürdig, dass er dachte, er hätte es gescannt und das wird wirklich genau begutachtet, weil die dann wahrscheinlich auch denken, vor einem Gericht hätte das keinen Bestand. Wenn die dieses Produkt drüberziehen über den Scanner und es aber nicht gescannt wurde, kann man wirklich den Kunden verantwortlich machen, dass der das scannt wie ein professioneller Supermarktkassierer oder nicht? Die werden wahrscheinlich schon genau wissen, ab wann es Diebstahl ist und ab wann es gibt es bestimmt so ein juristisches Wort mutwillig oder so glaubwürdig, nach bestem Glauben und Gewissen oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, man nachvollziehen kann, dass der wirklich dachte, er würde hier zahlen. Weiß man nicht. Was ja den Supermärkten hilft, sind ja diese Wagen. Denn meine Rewe, alle Theorien, die wir uns ersponnen haben, alle Ideen, die wir hatten, gehen gar nicht, weil bei mir im Supermarkt gibt es halt diese Waage. Und die, da bin ich noch nicht mit einem IQ 5000 Trick um die Ecke gekommen, die ist überlassen. Mir wurde es leider auch schon darauf hingewiesen, dass Kaufhausdetektive vermehrt darauf achten, wer von den Einkaufenden das Podcast-Ufer hört. Und wenn die merken, dass ihr auf eurem Smartphone gerade Podcast-Ufer laufen habt, dann nehmt ihr euch raus. Seid also da wirklich vorsichtig. Es ist wie 2014, ihr müsst den Merch wieder auf links drehen. Richtig, genau. Die Schals gibt es im Merch-Store, ansonsten haut rein, macht's gut, ich werde mich jetzt ausgenessen, ich leg mich hin. Dankeschön, haut rein und habt noch eine schöne Zeit, ich leg mich jetzt hin in unserem ganz kuscheligen Ufer. Ja, macht euch einen Tee, lasst euch gut gehen und lasst euch in Erkältungsbad ein. Macht's gut, ciao, ciao, tschüss, guter Küsse, tschüss.